Welcome to the lecture on database implementation. I'm Thomas Neumann. I'm a professor for database system here at the Technical University of Munich.
And as you all know, this semester, unfortunately, we have a very difficult time teaching. Namely, we will, at least in the beginning, and potentially for the whole semester, be able to do live presentation in a lecture with an audience, which is very unfortunate.
Which means that I will record the lectures, at least in the beginning and potentially the whole semester.
And you will have to watch a recording of this.
This is of course due to the difficulties, but for the teaching experience it is not ideal of course.
Therefore this semester it is more important than usual that you do the exercises.
because of course prepare exercises for you.
We also plan to have the submission of the exercises.
We plan to have interactive sessions and exercises
so you can ask questions if something is not clear.
So please engage in the exercise part
if you have questions, if you have difficulties
with the material that we cover.
So in this recording I will just talk about
and the question answering and training part is more done in the exercise.
Okay, so let's start with the lecture itself. So what are we talking about in the lecture?
So we are talking about the implementation of database systems. Now why do we care about this?
First, we see that database systems are extremely important. So they are used in nearly all cases
to manage very large quantities of data or where the data is particularly valuable.
So either if you have a lot of this or potentially both of course, or if you care about the value of
this, then database systems are probably over-hand for data solutions in most cases.
Of course we will see why this is the case and now we are ready to point on some key challenges
that we have. The first challenge is that we want to be able to scale to huge amounts of data. So it
should be easily possible to of course process gigabytes of data, no question about this. Terabytes
of data should also be feasible, perhaps even more than this. We want to support very, very large
volumes of data and we want to do this efficiently and we want to scale to large machines if we have
them available. This is one aspect. Another aspect that we care about is reliability,
which means that even if bad things happen like a power failure or your other
hand-file failure in your system or just a software failure, so a braking system
crashes or a data system crashes, all these kind of situations do occur and we
want to handle them various in the sense that we don't want to lose the data.
So we want everything works after the crash as it was before the crash.
So we are not supposed to lose data, in particular, we are not supposed to corrupt data.
So our database system must be consistent, even though it's had this catastrophic events.
And again, this is pretty difficult to guarantee, and most database systems do not offer this
kind of functionality.
And a third aspect that I want to highlight is concurrency.
So we want to allow that many people use our system concurrently, not only one user, but
many of these.
Everything should work, should scale, should give correct results, even with a large number
of users.
This is also a pretty difficult problem.
All this intelligence leads to a very complex software, a very complex infrastructure that
we must build.
Now, the challenge here is to build the system that even though it's complex, it's manageable,
we can understand how it works and we can evolve it over time.
This is also aspects that we want to look at in the lecture.
The goals of this lecture are first, we should learn how to build a modern database system.
So you look at many techniques that we can use on this.
Another goal is that we want to understand the internal of existing database systems.
Because even if you are not building a new database system, you might have to use an existing database
to understand how this works because often you can help the system and
configure the system in a way that it works better if you understand how the internals work.
The third goal of course is to understand the effects of hardware behavior,
particularly in the later part of the lecture. We will look at many things that
are affected by hardware. This is important for all kinds of high-performance processing.
Data systems, of course, want to take later. But even if later you are not working on data systems,
you might be working on similar problems where you have to process large amounts of data at
high speed. Therefore, this knowledge is also useful. The lecture is very roughly structured
in three large parts.
So we start with a classical database architecture.
So like if you look at the commercial systems
like Oracle SQL Server or this kind of beasts,
how are the architectures?
So we look at the traditional way
to architecture database system.
Then we will look at,
second part we will look at techniques
how to process queries or should say
how to process large volumes of data efficiently.
This, of course, is connected to the classical database architecture, but it already deviates
from this a bit.
We will see how we can do this particularly efficiently, how we can get fast.
And in the last part, we want to look at how we have to adapt the architecture to hardware
trends.
We see that the hardware is changing.
For example, one prominent trend is that we have much larger memory than we had in the
past.
We can't have machines with many gigabytes,
if perhaps even terabytes of memory.
This has some effect on the architecture.
We see that we have a large number of cores.
We can now buy processors that have 32 cores, 64 cores even.
If you look at recent processors by AMD.
And so this means that we have a very high degree
of parallelism in our system.
And again, this has some effect on the architecture
when we want to look at all of these aspects.
Now, which kind of literature can you use?
So, of course, we will cover all the material that you read.
If you're just interested in doing this course,
all materials that you need to be covered in the slides and in the exercises,
you don't have to read additional literature.
But if you want more details,
or if you want to just are interested in this topic
and just want to read more about this,
then we have three suggestions for you
about the database implementation.
The first one actually I considered the best
is a very nice and readable book.
Unfortunately, it's in German.
So this is coincidence.
And so it's the author,
as primarily the first author comes from Germany
and has written the book in German.
for a wider audience if we choose English instead.
So this one is TOH, Ehad Rahm,
Datemark Systeme, Konzepte and Techniken
der Implementierung.
It's a very nice book.
But of course, yeah, also other books
that talk about database implementation,
for example, the second one here,
Garcia Molina, Ullmann, Widem,
Database Systems, the complete book.
This also covers at least some aspects
of database implementation less than the first book,
but it does cover some.
And then there are of course more specialized books like the third one, Ray Reuter, Transaction Processing, a pretty well known one.
Particularly the aspect of transaction processing.
So this is already quite specialized.
So this is more if you are really interested in transaction systems.
Therefore this is also a widely known and useful book.
Now, the later parts of what we do in the lecture are unfortunately not covered by textbooks
yet most of the time.
These books mainly cover the classical architecture, so again, how the big players like Oracle
look like.
If you are interested in the later parts of the lecture and more details, you must unfortunately
read papers.
They are not all well-known textbooks yet.
Now, just to give you an idea why we are looking at an interesting problem.
So, why are database systems different than other programs?
Of course, there are many aspects to this.
We mentioned some already in the introduction.
So, there are many aspects like reliability, concurrency, and so on.
But one aspect I want to concentrate on in particular here is scalability.
So this is something that is really different between a database system and
at least the traditional way how people write small programs.
And just to make this easy to understand, we've looked at a very, very simple problem.
So we are giving two lists L1 and L2 and I want to find all entries that
occurs on both lists. So, it's a very simple problem. So, just to draw here an example instance
on the screen, I hope this is readable in the recording. So, let's say we have a list L1.
L1, and this contains A, X, B, Z. And then we have a list L2, and this contains perhaps A, B,
then we immediately see, okay, this element here occurs in both lists,
this element occurs in both lists, the other elements do not.
So a very simple problem. Now two lists, and you can probably, if you would ask you to
implement this in a programming language of your choice, you could probably need no more than
four lines of code or so to answer this. This is a very, very simple problem, at least in the
beginning. You will see in a moment that it's perhaps not as simple as you.
But the way I've written here, it's really simple. Now as I said, we are given
to lists, we want to find entries that occur on both lists. And this problem is
simple if both lists fit in my memory. So if the lists are small, then this is a
very simple problem. Now there's not only one solution to this, there are many ways.
So, many ways we could answer this.
Perhaps the most simple one is the following.
The most easy way to implement this,
I said I take my two lists.
So I said, the example I did previously was,
you had, I said, A, X, sorry, B, C,
and then this was L1, and then this was L2.
And this hits A, B, C, D, E.
Okay, now what I could do to answer this problem
is I could sort both lists.
Now this because I have written it this way,
A2 is already sorted, so I don't have to do anything.
A1 is not sorted, but I can sort it easily.
Sorry, it should go to C should be Y, I think.
So we say A, B, X, Y.
I had previously.
And so now I have two sorted lists
and now finding all elements that occur on both lists
is a very, very simple problem.
So now this is pretty easy.
So I just scan both lists here sequentially.
So I look at the first element on both lists.
This is either the same as in this case is yes.
So I'll put an A, say A is a match.
Then I go to the next element here.
B, B, is this the same?
Yes.
Now it goes to the next element as the same no.
Okay, now we have a difference.
So let's skip the smaller of the toes.
So we skip the C, then we come to D.
DX is the same no.
We skip the smaller one, so we skip the D, we come to E.
X equals E, no.
Then we skip the E and then we reach the end of the list.
Then we know that we have no.
So we know that we have exactly two common entries.
and we did this with one linear scan over both lists.
Now this was easy to implement and it's very fast.
Okay, but so intersecting two sorted lists is cheap and easy.
The main difficulty here is we have to sort the list.
So I had an example here with four elements,
but sorting four elements is trivial.
Now if you have a few million elements,
then it's still not very difficult,
but this costs you some time at least.
that sorting lists, and you have to realize
that I use the term list here loosely,
you don't want to implement this as a linked list.
Yeah, this would be terrible.
But let's say you implement it in some nice compact representation,
like a vector, and then we can sort this in n log n.
So this is not super expensive, but costs us something.
So we have more than linear runtime.
Now, the question is, how can we do better than this?
So how can we be faster than n log n?
And of course we can.
We can, for example, take the left side, build a hash table from this.
So again, I take my elements here, then I, let's just make something up.
So let's say this is my hash table and some more.
Then I take, for example, my a, this might add up here, hashed here.
So I take my a, then I hash my b, b adds up here.
Yeah.
And then I have my x, which I should have seen the other way around because I originally
list had the order A, X, B, Y, but nevertheless, so then I have an X, let's say this is here.
Then I have perhaps my Y is a collision, then I have another one here.
That's it. Okay, so I have a hash table. And then I take my other list. So that was the one
that I had here with which had A, B, C, sorry, supposed to be B, A, B, C, D, E. Then I take
my A, I hash it, I hash my A, I go to this list, find a hit. I take my B, hash it, go
to that list, find a hit. Take my C, hash it, go to, for example, this list because then I have a
So no hit.
Then I take my D, hash it, again have no hit and so on.
Now the example before is the way we first sorted
then it did intersection.
We had a runtime of N log N
because we dominated by sorting.
So sorting is expensive.
The intersection itself is then cheap afterwards.
So we do a linear scan, this is pretty cheap.
While here, our runtime is, question what our runtime is.
Now, we expect our runtime to be in O .
So because when I built my hash table, I look at every element, find the slot, put it in
there, takes constant time.
If I say it takes constant time, if I'm pedantic, I should modify my hash table.
Of course, it's likely to look like this.
It depends on how you implement it, of course, but most likely it will look like this.
But it doesn't matter, so we can read the hash table in constant time.
And then when we probe the hash table,
so maybe we read the other side,
for each element we compute a hash value,
takes constant time.
We go to an element in the hash table,
Then we check if it's equal,
and now if this takes constant time or not,
depends on how much faith you have in statistics
and how good your hash function is.
And so if you have a good hash function
and you don't have a lot of collisions,
hopefully no collisions or very few collisions,
it takes constant time, then we get end up
with linear runtime.
Okay, so, hash tables are usually better than sorting
if the data fits in memory.
Okay, so then we can get nice linear access time.
And so these are just two options.
Of course, there are many, many, many other ways.
You could use some other data structures
to search it instead of sorting.
We could use search trees,
So red-black trees also, usually you don't want to do this by the way.
Red-black trees are pretty slow, but we could, and some other mechanisms.
So we have many choices here.
And of course we will look at some details later in the lecture when we come to index
structures.
So this is already mentioned, so we could sort both lists and intersect, or build a
hash table, or build index structure, or many other alternatives.
Now note what is not an option.
So I will now write down some code that you will hopefully not use.
I just include it for completeness.
So if I would have asked an arbitrary programmer to say, please you have two lists, find all
entries that are current in both lists, you could be tempted to do the following.
I would say I do a for loop for x in L1, for y in L2, if x equals y is x.
So you could be tempted to do this.
Don't do this.
So don't do this.
even though it's just four lines of code, it of course has terrible runtime.
Because the runtime of this year is in the order of size of L1 times size of L2,
and this means, asymptotically, we have this word here, we have an n-square runtime.
where n is the size of the smaller list.
So, n is the list size,
And then we get n2 runtime.
Don't do this.
So n2 algorithms are usually a different system.
So we cannot use n2 algorithms.
So our algorithm have to be better than n2 usually.
Now why is this the case?
Because our n tends to be huge.
So if you have a database system,
then your n tends to be in the order of a few million,
perhaps even many million.
And clearly, if you say n is 1 million,
so then n squared is a really unpleasant number.
Because this here is 10 to the power of 6,
and then n squared here is 10 to the power of 12.
and 10 to the power of 12 is definitely a number
that you don't want to see in your execution time.
So, therefore, don't do this.
n square is not good.
As a rough rule of thumb, you can say,
in a database system, you only want to use algorithms
that have a runtime of n log n or better.
Now, admittedly, it's not always possible to get this,
but we want that everything that we do
is n log n or faster,
just because our n is so incredibly huge.
And if you have a huge n,
you cannot afford to do an n-square algorithm.
So this is one of the challenges
that we have when building a large scalable system.
Okay, now, again, I said the problem is,
simply if the data fits in memory,
what do we do if the data does not fit in memory?
So it could be that we have so many elements
in my database system that I cannot store all of them.
So what should we do?
Now there are good and not so good cases.
So the good case is, let's assume, remember we have two lists.
Let's assume one of the two lists does fit in memory.
Then everything is still okay.
So if one fits, let's say L1 is a smaller one, if L1 fits in memory but L2 does not,
that's okay, because the only thing I have to do is I take my L1, again I build a large
hash table here. So this is the hash table for L1.
So hash table for L1.
And then I take my L2. Now this L2 is huge,
but this doesn't matter. So even if it's really, really huge.
L1 I can't load in my memory. Then I read a part of L2 that fits
for example this one here. Then I probe the part that I've read
from here to my hash table and find all the matches.
Then I forget the part of L2 that I've read.
I read the next part.
Again, perform a lookup, find all the matches and so on.
So we just process L2 piece by piece
and we keep L1 in memory all the time.
This is nearly as simple as in memory case.
It's slightly more complicated, but it's not much.
So that's okay.
L2 just loads a smaller list into memory,
build some index structure or hash table or something.
We scan the large list and then we find all matches.
Really no big deal.
Now, of course, you probably see what's coming now.
Yeah, so the interesting case, of course,
is what happens if both lists are so large
that they do not fit in memory.
So we have a really, really large input.
If you wanted to intersect two lists
that are simply too large for my memory.
So for example, it could be that I have a memory
of 64 gigabytes, but my input is a terabyte.
So then I cannot keep it, so I must do something to still find the matches.
Now we come to external memory algorithms, and these tend to be much more nasty and difficult
than the in-memory case.
So first thing that you see is no direct interaction is possible.
So it's simply not tractable to compare elements from one list to the other, like in a loop
or anything like this.
This is infeasible.
Because accessing something from external memory,
so worst case, a rotating disk,
but even if it's not a rotating disk,
but an SSD, which is much faster,
even then accessing the SSD,
it's much, much, much, much slower than memory.
So we cannot just go to the disk and read something.
This is not too expensive.
We cannot do this.
Now, what we could do,
we could use sorting.
We could take the two lists,
then sort the two lists,
and then the intersection.
Because after sorting,
the problem is easy.
Remember how the intersection
of two sorted lists worked.
So we just take two by two sorted lists here.
And I start reading in the beginning,
and I always skip the smallest element
until I have a match.
So this is the strategy, basically.
And this works, of course, beautifully,
lists are too large.
Because I just read the next element
and of course I have to go to disk
from time to time to fetch the next
block of data from
disk, but that's okay, because in memory
I only have to keep one element.
So I can easily keep this
and I can do this kind of processing for
arbitrary large lists. This works beautifully.
The main problem here
is sorting.
How do I sort
a list that does not fit in memory?
cover this as a lecture, so you might know this,
or if you encountered in a lecture on algorithms
and data structures, you might have heard about
n-way sorting, for example, this is one technique
to do this.
There are algorithms to sort data that is larger
in memory.
For now we ignore this, we're just saying, okay,
this is one approach, but this is difficult.
Or the alternative is, you use a kind of partitioning
scheme, which means you break your problem
into smaller problems until the smaller problems fit in memory.
And this is usually an attractive solution, but this is again much more difficult than what we
did before. So for example, what we can do is, I take here, this is my, again, I have a very large
input here, this is a very large input, and now I read my input. For example, this I can fit in
the parts that I can fit in memory, and then I partition it, which means I split this into
multiple groups.
For example, I say every value between 0 and 100 comes here, this bucket.
Then everything between 100 and 1000 or so comes here, and so on.
So I have many, many buckets, and I organize all my elements in buckets.
So I do this for the first chunk, then I do this for the next chunk, again, distributing
it in different buckets and so on.
I do this for all my input.
And afterwards I know that the first bucket contains always between 0 and 100, the second
one between 100 and 1000 and so on.
And I did this hopefully in a way such that each bucket fits in my memory.
So that I can keep it in my memory.
If it does not fit, I must use more buckets.
So I just must use more partitions.
Use as many partitions as I need
until the result fits in memory.
And once I have done this,
then we come back to the example we had before,
namely data fits in memory.
Now again, we have two choices.
Either we partition both sides,
so then we can fall back to the real in-memory case,
or we just partition one side,
then we come back to the case
advantage is we need less partitioning, disadvantage is we read the other side
multiple times, also not super attractive. Usually we want to partition both sides.
I just sketched a solution here, we will look at more examples how this
recursive partitioning works in the lecture when we come to external memory
hashing because, sorry, external memory joints because this is exactly what's the
And I'm just saying this is already much, much more complex.
So we must read my input, I must partition it,
I must make sure my partitions are not too large,
and all kinds of special cases that can occur.
So external memory is much more difficult.
Now this is particularly hard,
it's not if the input is not only large,
but if you make no assumptions about L1 and L2.
Okay, so if my algorithm must work for arbitrary L1 and L2,
this is a really, really difficult problem
because arbitrary, unfortunately, includes many corner cases
that you would think, oh, this will never occur in practice,
but it can occur.
Yeah, so we don't know this.
And so, yeah, so there are many, many corner cases
that we perhaps have to cover.
Yeah, so for example, what never was the case
for my example here,
The list might contain duplicates.
Now if it's a true duplicate in the sense that the elements are really identical, then
it doesn't matter because we can just collapse them.
But it could be that, or often will be the case, that it's a duplicate with attached additional
information, which means you have a certain value and this has additional information
that we must preserve, which means we cannot just remove duplicates, but we must keep them
and we must output the duplicates correctly.
So this occurs quite frequently.
and then the duplicates
create
problems for us.
So we must cope with this problem
that we have duplicates and we must
preserve them in the output.
And now it could be very unlucky
that we have so many duplicates
that even a single duplicate exceeds my memory
size. So I have this one
value with attached extra
information that is so
frequent that
I cannot store even
all instances of this single value
in memory. Now this breaks my simple external memory logics that just say,
hey choose smaller partitionings and everything fits, because this never happens.
So it's just impossible to partition the data so that it fits because of this
duplicate problem. Now there are many ways to solve this. For example, you could
recognize this. You could say, I know this is one value that occurs very very often.
So just store separately.
So store the extra information somewhere else,
the key only once,
and then when we do find a match on the other list,
then we reconstruct all my pairs and outputs.
So we can't special cases, but again, this needs code.
So we must write this.
Or there are other ways to tackle this,
but all of them require us to write something.
And database systems have the particular problem
implement them you don't know what the user will do with them later.
Basically implement them once, then you give them to somebody else and this
somebody else will store data inside that you have no idea about
beforehand what this data will be. So you can insert everything and if your
system is supposed to handle everything reasonably well, so gracefully, then we
must code for all the special cases that can occur. This means of course
that the code complexity is very high.
It can be very high because of all the things
that we must cover.
And so to handle all this here correctly,
we will definitely meet many hundred lines of code,
potentially thousands of lines of code.
And this in contrast to this trivial four line,
trivial four loops that we did in the beginning.
And so if you use an E4 loop,
we need four lines of code.
If you want to do this in a scalable way
memory size, we will need probably thousands of lines of code.
So code complexity is definitely an issue.
Now, so this highlights the problems.
Of course, we are more interested in solutions.
Therefore, we will in the lecture see how we can design a system that is such that we can
implement all this reasonably easy, so that we don't have to write this thousand lines of code
every time, but we just build infrastructure so that we can rely upon the infrastructure and then
for example, is simply intersect reasonably easy. So it's not that bad.
Okay, so in general, coming back from the list intersection example, if you want to
design scalable algorithms for different kinds of problems, then this is very hard.
Well, this is very difficult to do this, because you must cope with very large instances.
You could get very large input.
This is difficult even in memory.
So there is a pretty nice book
that's actually talking about more information retrieval problems
than about database problems.
But this has a funny, very nice book title.
And this is called Managing Gigabytes.
Now, what's particularly interesting about this book
is that the book is already quite a few years old.
It's not new, it's probably at least 20 years old.
and of course in this time
a gigabyte was more than it is today
because for us a gigabyte
you have memory that's larger
than this but the interesting thing is
that even today
doing non-trivial processing
in a few gigabytes of data is difficult
even though it easily
fits in memory but
if the number of elements that you have
is large enough or if you have millions
of elements, tens or hundreds
of millions of elements or in
elements, then algorithmic complexity becomes an issue.
Clearly, we cannot do anything that has an n-square runtime.
n-square runtime just doesn't scale if n is large.
So we must be better.
And if we have to do this in external memory, which means we cannot just load everything
in memory, but we must handle disks, then everything becomes even worse, of course.
And this requires us to build systems very carefully, such that we have building blocks available to implement all the algorithms that we need efficiently and scalable.
And this is basically what we want to look at in the lecture.
Now, one particular technique that we use to get scalable performance is something that we call set-oriented processing.
Now, what is set-oriented processing?
Before we come to that, perhaps we look at how typical small applications look like.
If you write some of Python code or any other programming language, it's very easy and very
natural to say, hey, I have this collection of elements, I just loop over all elements
and then I do some operation.
So this is, remember the example that I did in the beginning, where we say, hey, for x in L1, for y in L2.
So this is something that I would consider loop-oriented programming here.
So then we say, if, doesn't matter, I say it's x equals y or something else, then we do some something.
So this is a very natural way to code this.
Unfortunately, natural is bad.
So, it looks easy and nice, but we don't want this.
Because this is inherently n-square runtime.
You multiply the number of elements in L1 with the number of elements in L2, and this doesn't scale.
So we are not supposed to do this.
So looping of elements is bad.
What we want instead is, we want set-oriented processing.
we don't look at one element and another element, but we look at large groups of elements, for
example all the input elements or potentially not all, but at least large sets of them.
So we look at large batches of data and then we do something with a large batch of data and another
large batch of data. And this gives me much better, or can at least give me much better runtime.
Now concrete algorithms to process these sets, we'll look at later.
But first, what are the high level primitives that we want to process on sets of input elements?
We start with something that you hopefully all remember very well from your introduction to database lecture.
And this is a relational algebra.
So these are the basic primitives that we can perform on relations and these are of course
by definition set oriented.
So we don't look at individual elements, but we take one set, another set and then we combine
them in a certain way and then we get an output.
So now first some notation to mean you hopefully all remember this from the introductory course,
but just for completeness some notation.
So we say we denote with AE the attributes of tuples produced by E, so E is an arbitrary expression.
Another way, instead of A of E, what you could say, this is a schema.
So A of E is a schema of the elements.
If I produce columns ABC, then A of my expression is ABC.
So this is a schema, the attributes.
Now, f are the three variables. I'm not sure if you need this in the beginning here.
So this matters if you have variables that come from the outside, for example,
for correlated subqueries, then my f contains entries here. I will cover this again. We
come to this later in the lecture. Just for reference, f are the three variables.
Now, if we perform a binary operation,
like union intersect a difference,
then we usually require that the schema of the one side
and the schema of the other side is the same.
Now for completeness, if you do a join or a cross product,
then of course we require something else.
Namely, that we require that.
So for example, if we have E1 cross E2 requires,
that the schema of E1 and the schema of E2 is destroyed.
Because the same attribute must not occur on both sides.
So this is the same for cross products, for set operations
because it is the same.
Now, which operations can we perform?
So, of course, these are the standard operations that we know.
So, we have a union.
We just take two sets of elements and we just combine them.
Intersection, find all elements that occur on both sides.
This is basically the introductory example that we did.
We find everything that occurs on both sides.
Then, set difference, find everything on the left side that does not occur on the right
side.
Then, here we have a rename operator.
And so we just want to figure out, sorry, we don't, we just want to rename one column.
So let's say if we had a column that was previously named A, we now want to name it B.
So in construction, if we do this, we take my X, we add a new column B, this has a value
X of A, and we remove the column A with a value X of A.
So then we rename a column.
Then projection, we just retain a set of attributes here.
We keep all attributes A in by subscript A.
Otherwise we discard them.
So we just project to these elements.
The next one, cross product.
We take all elements from E1, all elements from E2,
and we combine them into one.
Here, of course, remember I said we don't want to use an n-square operation, n-square is evil.
If you look at the cross-product, then clearly this here has a runtime of n-square.
Because my output is n-square, and of course I cannot be faster than my output.
So no algorithm can be faster than its output.
Therefore, cross-products are an n-square operation.
And coming back to what I said in the beginning, we do not want to do cross-products.
Cross products are bad.
If you can avoid it,
we never want to use a cross product.
Sometimes, rarely, they are unavoidable.
Then we have to do this, of course,
but we don't want to do this.
Cross products are really, really bad.
Okay, so next selection.
So we just keep all tuples where a certain predicate is true.
Everything else is discarded.
And then the join, conceptually, the join is, of course,
So we could say that R1 join R2 is equivalent to R1 cross R2, followed by a predicate P,
a theta predicate P. This is true concerning the result, but of course this is not true concerning
the implementation. A join we can implement efficiently, so we can find algorithms that
So this can be implemented in...
It is dangerous to say something here.
So let's say this can be implemented efficiently,
whatever efficiently is,
while this one here is inherently bad.
So this here is in n-square runtime.
Now is this here better?
Let's say this can be implemented,
In O of size of R1 plus size of R2 plus result size of R1 join R2.
This is not always true unfortunately. Let's say in many cases.
cases in this class.
Not always, but in many cases, particularly the frequently used cases, we can implement
it in this runtime.
And then this is of course passed.
I must read my input, so this is okay, I must read my input, I must read my other input,
and I must produce my output.
And therefore this here has an ideal runtime, in many cases, not in all cases.
We will look at the implementation of joints later.
Here I just want to list the definition.
So joint combines two lists, two relations, and finds all pairs where certain conditions
are true.
Now all these operations are inherently set-oriented because we have defined them on sets.
So clearly we are set-oriented.
If you are really pedantic, we must say that in the database system, strictly speaking,
we will not use sets, but we will use backs.
A back means a multi-set, so a set that can contain duplicates.
If you remember back about SQL, SQL allows you to output a value that occurs multiple times.
We can have a relation that contains column X, then has a value 1, 2, 2.
In a mathematical relation this would not be possible because in a set this would not be possible because this value occurs two times.
So in a set this cannot be the case because a set can only contain one and two.
But in the real implementation we have multi-sets which means we are allowed to produce duplicates.
So this requires some extra care but at least for now we can ignore this and just say hey we operate on sets.
everything is duplicate free. When we deviate from this we mentioned this in the lecture.
These were the basic operations you know from your introductory lectures. These are
some derived operators that you can express them using the already existing ones,
but they are also useful, at least some of them. The first two here I just included for completeness
a so-called natural join, so a join without explicit join predicates.
So this is, we join two sides here, a1 and a2, and then my, if you look at this one here,
it's an equality condition.
Find all elements from e1, all x from e1 and all y from e2, which are the same concerning
the attributes that occurs on both sides.
So here we take the schema of e1, the schema of e2, intersect it, and this gives me all
and then I restrict my equality predicate to these attributes.
So I want that these attributes are the same.
The so-called natural join.
So we include everything, we join on the commonly-equal predicate.
And also you see in the result construction,
we restrict y to the attributes that occur only on the right-hand side.
The common attributes are removed,
because they are the same of course,
due to this equality condition.
is what you find in textbooks.
If you ask me, nobody ever uses natural joins.
I mean, at least no system.
So humans like natural joins because they're easy to write.
So you can make nice textbook examples for natural joins.
But no database system uses natural joins
because internally, every column will get a unique name
anyway.
So what your query compiler will do from your SQL query,
it will most likely assign a unique name to each column.
never occurs because we have no column that occurs on both sides.
That's just a no issue.
But I include it nevertheless because you find it in textbooks.
Same with relational division.
As we find all elements from the left side
that can be combined with all values from the right side.
In a way, this is the inverse of a cross product.
Therefore, this is the name division.
you can use this to implement all quantifiers in SQL.
Again, nobody uses this.
Okay, a few people.
But I'm not aware of any systems that would make use of this.
So these are here, textbook.
So these are textbook examples.
You find them in books, but not in systems.
The entries below this line, these are not textbooks, these are real.
So these are used for implementing database systems.
So semi-joints, we want to find all elements from the left side that do have a joint partner
on the right hand side.
So we look at elements from the left, all x from the left, and then we check if there
exists an element on the right where the predicate is true.
It doesn't matter if it is 1 or 20,000, we just care yes or no.
Is there a joint partner, yes or no?
And if yes, we output it, if no, we discard x.
And then the anti-joint, this is a complement of the semi-joint.
So we output everything where there is not a joint partner.
Now you could ask yourself why do we need this.
I can already tell you this year corresponds roughly to
this year corresponds roughly to exists in SQL.
exists as an existential quantifier and this here corresponds roughly to the price not exists.
Okay, so we can use this to translate quantifier expression and sequel with semijoints and antitrions.
And there are also some other use cases. And in fact life is difficult,
For example, not exist with anti-joins works unless you can, for some strange reason, have
null results, which unfortunately sometimes occur.
But if you ignore this, then exist maps to semi-joins, not exist maps to anti-joins, except
for some special cases.
And then the next one here, outer-joins.
So we output everything from, so this is basically a regular join followed by, so this here is a regular join followed by, we find all elements that did not find a joint partner.
For this here we use anti-joint, we find all elements that do not have a joint partner.
And then we output them regardless and we pad the missing values here with nulls.
So we take a look at all the values from E2 which were missing, we had a null there and
then we add them anyway.
So this here is a left outer join.
We output everything that either has a join partner or does not have a join partner and
pad it with nulls.
You get this for two reasons.
either if the user asks for it, because in SQL you can write, so you can say table 1 or some other subquery here, then left autojoin
table 2 on x equals y.
This corresponds directly to an autogoint.
So this is an explicit autogoint in the query.
There are other ways you can get autogoints.
For example, if somebody does, see this here,
you say select, select, then some stuff,
and then you do inside the select, you do another select here.
select y from and some other.
So this implicitly also creates an auto join.
Because if this inner result here is empty,
so if you do not find a y, then we get a null.
And if you get more than one y, you get an error message.
But nevertheless, this corresponds to a special kind of auto joins.
So that we call them single join because you're only allowed to have one joint partner.
But this corresponds roughly to an auto join.
And finally, we have a full auto join that is in a way the combination of left and right
auto join.
Which means we take the regular join and then output everything from the left that does
not have a joint partner.
Then everything from the right that does not have a joint partner.
Note that this here only holds the simple union because we use set semantics.
With back semantics this does not work because we would include the regular join result twice.
So this is a combination of left and right join only with sets.
If you have duplicates, we must be more careful than we just take the regular join
and add everything padded from left and from the right.
Again, you can ask for this in SQL using full outer join.
Now, up to now this part you have probably already seen in your introductory lecture.
These are some operators that you might not have seen in introductory lecture, but we
nevertheless need.
So for real SQL support we need some more constructs.
The first one here is a map operator.
Basically we construct a new column.
So we say we want to output the new column A and we want that for we construct the new
by evaluating a function f on my input attributes.
Now why do we need this? For example, it's very simple reasons.
Somebody says, select
x plus y as z.
Okay? From r.
So if you do this in SQL, if you translate this in relation algebra like this,
I take my relation R, then I do a map and I say the column Z has the value X plus Y.
So this is a way to compute a new column by evaluating a function.
So this is a map function. Then we have a group by an aggregate. So I take my input,
group it by a certain number of attributes,
then evaluate a function f.
This again corresponds to,
so if I in SQL would do,
select
some
x
s
from
r
group by
by ABC. This corresponds to the relation algebra construct. Take my relation R, then I add, on top of this, I add a group by. I group by ABC and then evaluate the aggregation function.
So this is how we can translate group by and SQL into algebra using a group by operator.
And finally dependent join, here we come back to the three variables that we had before.
So this looks like a join but behaves slightly differently.
Namely, what we do here is we have two expressions e1 and e2 and we evaluate the expression e1
for the values from e2.
We take an x from e1 and then we take a y from e2 evaluated for x.
That works. To make an algebra example, we say I want to output, I have R1, then I do here a dependent join.
and the dependent join says say r1.x equals r2.y then i have here in r2.
Note that this part here is problematic because we try to evaluate predicate
but using the values from r1 and r2 but at this point i do not have r1 available.
So if you look at this part, so we ignore the rest.
Let's look at this box.
Just look at the box.
This relational attribute operator is not well formed.
Why? Because we are accessing attributes that does not exist.
R1 doesn't exist, because within the box I only have R2,
and I can evaluate R2.y, no problem,
but I cannot evaluate R1.x,
whereas this doesn't exist.
So therefore we call r1.x, so the f of my box here is r1.x.
So this is a free variable, which means I don't know it.
So I have to bind it.
And this is exactly what the dependent join does.
The dependent join says within the right hand side,
you please use the following value.
namely we use my x, pass it into the right hand side and then we can evaluate this.
So regular joint wouldn't work, but dependent joint does work.
I just evaluate this box for the template from the left side.
Now clearly this here has again n2 runtime.
Why? Because I take a element from the left and then evaluate the right hand side for each element from the left.
This is bad.
Therefore, what the system will try to do is, it will try to remove all dependent joins.
Dependent joins are performance-wise very, very bad. We don't want to do this.
But there are SQL constructs that force us to do this.
The most trivial example you can construct is this one here.
You say select star from 1.
Now we start a subquery, select star from R2 where R1.x equals R2.y.
And if you have this, then you get exactly this construct.
And you get exactly dependent join. Now the dependent join again are terrible,
Therefore the first thing the system will do is to try to remove the dependent join.
And you can hopefully easily see that you can transform this one here into
1.join2
on the attribute
y.x equals 2.y.
Okay, you can rewrite this so that the predicate moves up to the join, then it's no longer dependent
and then we can use regular joins and everything is good.
Okay, so in this simple case it's easy to do, but I can write much more complicated SQL statements.
It's not that easy to remove the correlation.
Therefore, systems do support dependent join.
Now just for nomenclation, if you look at for example SQL server,
SQL server doesn't call this dependent join, they call this I think cross apply.
So cross apply, but nevertheless, this is the same as the dependent join.
We evaluate the right-hand join side for the left-hand side.
Now, why are we interested in set-oriented processing?
Because we can implement this much more efficiently.
So if you are processing not one value and one value, but if you are processing the million values and the million values,
then we can perform operations that make the whole process more efficient.
For example, we can build an index structure.
Or we can reorganize the data like partitioning.
Or we can use sorting or hashing.
So we can do something with our data that we could not do if we just look at individual values.
And this preprocessing makes the whole process more efficient.
In the end, we want that all algorithms have a runtime of n log n or better, ideally.
To be fair, this is not always possible.
If the user asks me to produce an n-square output, I cannot be faster than n-square.
But if the user does not force me to produce an n-square output, then I want to be faster
than n-square.
So n log n is what we want to have.
And now there are many ways to achieve this, many algorithms we can use.
We look at them much later in the lecture, we're still in the introductory chapter here.
I just want to highlight to you what are the challenges, what are the techniques that we want to use.
Okay, now traditionally when we build database systems, we make a number of assumptions.
So traditionally in the sense that if you built a system 20 or 30 years ago,
assumptions. First we assume that data is much larger than my memory. So not only a bit larger,
it's much larger. And therefore my whole processing is dominated by I.O. So by input output.
So reading data from disk or writing data to disk dominates everything. It's much more important
than what I do in memory. And a corollary of this is, again giving the hardware that I had 20 or 30
years ago that random
access to my data
is very very expensive because I would
have to do this as random IO so
which means I would have to move
ahead on a rotating disk
and this takes very long time
so just to give you an idea
doing a random access on a
rotating disk
costs you something like
in the ballpark of let's say
4 milliseconds if you're
lucky it's just 3 or so
but random access on a rotating disk is in the ballpark of 4 milliseconds.
This means that we can only do roughly 250 random accesses per second.
Roughly.
250 is not a very impressive number.
250 is a very low number.
So which means that if you want to access 1000 data elements and you do this at random,
we need 4 seconds for this.
And this is forever.
So we cannot do this.
So random access on a rotating disk is terribly expensive.
And therefore, systems said we must never do this or extremely rarely do this.
So we try to avoid random I.O. whenever we can.
So this was the traditional model.
we were dominated by disk excess,
disk excess is slow,
and random disk excess is even more slow.
This was the assumption that we made.
And when you build a database system
using these assumptions,
you get two things.
You get a very conservative model,
because you never want to do random excess and so on,
but you also get a very scalable model.
So this is a good part.
So if you look at the systems that are built at this time,
they did scale pretty well.
So even to very large amounts of data.
So they work fine, but they are very conservative.
Now, if you look at how the hardware looks today,
and not 20 or 30 years ago,
we see that many things have changed.
In particular, we see that memory has increased dramatically.
So you can easily buy a machine that has a terabyte of memory.
It's not very expensive.
I mean, it's not exactly cheap either.
but you pay for this a bit more than 10,000 euro probably.
So it's not super expensive.
Compared to the cost of a programmer,
this is actually quite cheap.
So a company can easily buy a machine with terrible memory.
You probably don't want to do this at home,
unless your budget is a bit higher
than I would have expected.
But for companies, it's not a big deal.
So you can easily do this.
And if you have such a large amount of memory,
then of course, this success gets much more rare.
access is much more infrequent and therefore we are no longer dominated by
the disk I.O. but perhaps by in-memory processing. Another thing that we see is
that people are moving away from rotating disks and we tend to use
solid-state drives or flash storage and these allow much faster random I.O.
Even in these beasts it's cheaper to read large blocks of data than
effect of random access. So you can only do a finite number of random accesses per second on
these machines. But this finite number is much, much, much, much higher than a rotating disk.
Yes, you can easily do thousands of random access per second, many thousands of random
access per second, which you could never do on a rotating disk. So hardware has changed,
therefore the old assumptions are not necessarily true. This has some consequences for the design
of a database system. First, what we see is CPU costs suddenly become much more expensive,
much more important. In the past, while we are waiting on disk, disk is so incredibly slow,
that it doesn't matter that much what we do with the CPU. It does matter when we start burning
CPU massively, but as long as we were reasonably with our CPU, then disk error was everything.
This is no longer the case, because data is in memory to begin with, at least often,
and then disk I.O. doesn't matter at all.
We only look at CPU processing.
So CPU becomes important.
Because we often have no I.O. at all, or only very little.
And then if you do I.O., we could potentially afford to do a bit more random I.O. than we did in the past.
Because my I.O. device is much faster and it does allow for random access.
And this means that the old architecture that people have used in the past has become suboptimal.
So, you can run a traditional database architecture on a modern system.
It will work, no problem, but it will not give you an ideal performance.
Of course, we will look at the aspect of this in the lecture.
But on the other hand, this is more an evolution than a revolution.
So this doesn't mean you have to throw away all your database systems.
It just means that you have to change something.
You must change some of the techniques, but some of the things that we used in the past
And therefore, we start by looking at the traditional architecture also because this
is what you will mostly encounter if you look at the big commercial vendors.
They still tend to be more designed like a traditional database system.
Therefore, we start with this.
And then we look at how we can adapt this to scale better to modern hardware design.
The goals that you have in the database system is ideally we want the following.
First we want to be able to handle arbitrary large amounts of data.
If we want to do this efficiently.
It doesn't matter if you have a gigabyte or if you have many terabytes.
Everything should work smoothly and efficiently for arbitrary sizes.
Now another goal is we never want to lose data.
It doesn't matter what happens if we have a crash, software crash, power failure, whatever.
We never want to lose data.
This, of course, also requires care.
Then we want to offer a high-level interface to manipulate and retrieve data.
Usually, in our case, it's a SQL, but could also be something else.
We also have some high-level API.
We want to shield the application from the complexity of data management,
which means that this application just says,
hey, here's my data, please store it, please retrieve it for me.
do this internally. Store it and prostrate it as it works best for my use case.
This is what we want, that the system does it automatically or at least mostly
automatically. And of course we want to get excellent performance for all kinds
of queries and all kinds of data. No assumptions about the data. Do you have
skew in the data, so uneven distribution? Do you have duplicates? Doesn't matter.
It should work in all cases. This is our goal and this is of course a very
satisfy all these goals. On the other hand, we usually can do this
just with added complexity in the software. But that's okay, because this is a deal
that we made when we built a database system. Database systems are
pretty difficult to build, but you build them only once
or a few times. There are not that many database systems
out there. Actually, there are many database systems, if you are honest.
But nevertheless, there are even more applications out there
than database systems.
So usually one database system can be used by many different kinds of applications.
Therefore, it's just worthwhile to spend the implementation effort and do it once, and then
everybody can profit from this.
So then this here is a rough overview of what we want to do in the lecture.
So we start with the classic architecture, which means we look at how traditional database
systems are organized.
We start with storage. So how do we store data on disk or on a physical medium?
Then we look at access paths. If you don't know what access paths means, first
approximation, an access path is an index structure. So how can we access my data
efficiently? How can we find my data efficiently? Then we look at transactions
and recovery. So how can we cope with concurrent users and how can we cope with
crashes. This covers the first big part of the lecture. Next big part is
efficient query processing. So how do we set oriented processing? How do we
implement this efficiently? How can we pass data around and so on? Then we look at
the algebraic operators. How can we implement all of them efficiently? So
that we can get fast answers for all these primitives. And third part here is
code generation. If we have a query, how do we translate this into something
executable? Because ultimately we must execute a query. Because we want to get
results, we must execute the query. How do we do this? And in the third part,
designing a database system for the modern hardware. So what do we
have to change in the storage architectures to cope with, for example,
large main memory. Then how do you optimize cache locality and finally if you are building a main
memory database system so that assumes that all my data is memory nearly all the time what we have
to do there because this affects not just storage but many other parts like transaction processing
and recovery and so on. And this is a brief overview over the lecture. Okay so I will stop here with
recording for the first part, I will record the subsequent part as we go
through the semester. And remember, please look at the exercise sites at
Moodle and everything that we provide here for you. This semester will be more
difficult than usual because of the lack of interactive teaching, unfortunately.
But we do our best to try to cover this in the exams.
Sorry, it's exercise.
Okay, thank you.